Pokemon's sword and shield are finally
out but now comes the hard part
which version should you get regardless
of which one you pick up the core
adventure will be the same across both
titles so you can generally expect to
encounter similar characters Pokemon and
story beats whether you're playing sword
or shield
however as has been the case since the
series began each version will also
feature some distinct elements so the
experience will differ somewhat
depending upon which game you play
traditionally the biggest difference
between Pokemon games is which monsters
you can capture in the wild but some
installments have shaken things up and
more dramatic ways with version
exclusive locations and characters here
are all the differences you can expect
and a first for the series pokemon sword
and shield will feature some version
exclusive gym leaders some cities in the
gala region will be home to different
gyms depending on which version you're
playing pokemon sword is home to be the
fighting gym leader and gordy the Rock
Gym Leader shield on the other hand has
Alistar the ghost gym leader and Melanie
the ice gym leader while the gym
missions look different they largely
play out the same just as in the past
sword and shield will each be a home to
a handful of pokemons that can't be
captured in the other version here's the
full list of exclusive pokemon also it's
entirely possible I might mess these
names up so please blame me Kurt the vo
guy not the writer sorry in advance
sword exclusives Z dot nuzzle eat and
ship free swirlix and slurpuff scraggy
scraf t go theta goth Arita goth Arita
got the tella rough 'let breviary
mo while i'm a while
Farfetch'd in sir fetched passing me and
tur donator tirta own a derp do that
what again turnout turnout turnout
terr donator Solrock gallery' and
Darumaka and Daraa meant Manhattan
Dharam darm Anacin Dino Dino zou zou
Aeolus zoo ælis and hydrogen hydrogen
ding mo kako mo and okay wait glad I got
it
hakimoto and como za Chien I think I got
that one right
shield exclusives lotad lombre and
Ludicolo spritzee and a rome at ro mat
to see to say
spritzee and ara mat to say Kuro gunk
Kurt Kuro cara gunk and Toxicroak solo
sis du Chien ruin Achilles that wasn't
right valla by and manda buzz
Sableye gallery' and pone pone Ponyta
okay I could do that one Glorian Ponyta
and rapid - Lauren goo or anger guru or
in guru Grampa lunatone go re and Korra
solo and curse Ola glory and corsola and
curse Ola lavatory larvae thar Bupa
pupitar and tyrant our goomy sliggoo and
goodra sama Zonta
that was horrible okay both versions
also feature a new Pokemon named Apple
in with exclusive evolutions and sword
you can get an item that evolves Appling
to flap 'el and in shield you can find
an item that evolves it into appleton
like previous games sword and shield are
each presented by a different legendary
Pokemon the cover of sword is adorned by
Zion which wields a sword in its MA and
moves about gracefully while shields
cover is graced by zama Zenta which
boasts an armor like mane hopefully this
video helps you in deciding which
version to get that is unless you just
get both of them either way good luck on
your journey to becoming a Pokemon
master and to be the best the best there
ever was make sure to come back here to
gain spot for everything pokemon sword
and shield thanks for watching
[Music]